Rachel not her real name was physically
and mentally abused by her husband with
control over her finances part of a
pattern of threatening behavior her
words have been spoken by an Al Jazeera
producer despite me earning more than
twice his monthly salary my former
partner refused to put my name on a
utility bill which prevented me from
acquiring my own bank account as a
result my wages were deposited into his
account for which he did not provide me
with the passwords I would later
discover that he spent the majority of
my earnings without my knowledge or
consent
Rachel was in the UK on a spousal Visa
at the time and unable to seek
government financial support she feared
destitution if she left her abusive
partner like Rachel economic abuse
occurs when someone's ability to access
their income sabotaged that could
include directly taking a person's pay
or controlling their working hours or
denying them access to things like a car
or a mobile phone many survivors talk of
running up huge debts through loans or
credit cards often without their
knowledge we see online banking being
misused regularly online Financial
accounts on those shopping accounts not
just used to to monitor spending but
also location tracking the perpetrator
is able to manipulate and coerce a
Survivor into handing over passwords or
PIN numbers to those accounts Financial
uncertainty during the pandemic and now
a sharp increase in the cost of living
have seen the number of reported cases
of economic abuse saw according to
research by the charity Refuge 16
percent of adults in the UK that's 8.7
million people say they've experienced
economic abuse with as many as 39 saying
they've experienced controlling Behavior
over their finances suggesting some
degree of abuse
the vast majority are women
for 1.6 million the abuse started during
the covid-19 pandemic
following economic abuse one in five
survivors are left with debts of
thousands of dollars they feel unable to
repay
this represents 17 billion dollars of UK
debt directly due to economic abuse
prompted several of the country's
leading Banks such as HSBC to launch
campaigns helping victims to Take Back
Control while the British government's
issuing Frontline staff including debt
collectors and police with new training
to identify and respond to economic
abuse support Rachel struggled to find
when she needed it most
Neve Barker Al Jazeera London